as a customer experience leader or
manager your goal is to advocate
for what our customers need and you know
going back to data that needs to be
backed with mountains of data and
mountains of of uh
actual information tangible information
that you can then bring as is kind of
like proof or as an an argument
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctek
hello hello and welcome to another
episode of 20 minute leaders meet deron
prilook vice president of customer
experience
glassesusa.com
theron is a leader in customer
experience with over a decade of
experience scaling up customer solutions
and professional services teams for
companies such as wix guesty and now
glasses usa as an entrepreneur and
business owner himself the rome brings
an array of knowledge about how to
create outstanding customer experiences
and teams
dawn prilook welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so so much for being
here
thank you for having me
wow we're going to have a great time i i
have way too many questions to even
begin talking about your incredible
journey in some of the most incredible
companies from wix to vp customer
experience at gusty to vp of customer
experience currently at glasses usa all
incredible companies with many more in
the middle that that i don't even have
time to mention now but are also
incredible a jolt instructor but i have
to start off with you as a coach for the
special olympics i know you're an
athlete well right let's start over
there what what is that how do you do
that
so that that takes me back like almost
20 years ago which makes me feel kind of
old
which is fine i am kind of old um but
actually i did it for a year um there's
a there's a thing in israel called the
or i guess
you know gap year community service here
or whatever
um
and i lived in oahuda and we did a lot
of educational stuff and
for me i was already into sports and i
was looking for some like extra
curricular volunteering type of
activities to do and i i stumbled upon
special olympics
ended up coaching soccer and basketball
and it was just exposed to an amazing
international organization
that until this day just does amazing
amazing initiatives even in israel to
this day by the way so
i i love it i actually watch much more
of the special olympics than the regular
olympics i think most people should
transition most of their viewing time
there because i think there's too many
life lessons to be learned and too much
inspiration to be gained
customer
experience as a position
yes
what is that
so
it's funny you know i i
i think a lot of people still
um
to this day kind of get confused you
know let's take a step back i think to
me the best way to understand customer
experience and when i when i teach my uh
my uh customer experience course at jolt
the first thing i do is i play two
minute video by jeff bezos from 1999 it
became super famous i think it was
coined like the internet schmidt
internet
speech it was like an interview if you
haven't seen it google it after
and it's 1999 right
and jeff bezos basically makes the whole
spiel about how customer experience is
going to make or break amazon
fast forward you know two decades later
he had some some knowledge or some
understanding of the value of customer
experience so
today there's like
i i don't know if i should call it
streams or or like uh
different elements or or schools that
comprise
the the big uh term or or
a field of customer experience it can be
support it can be self-service it can be
a a
knowledge management it can be customer
success by the way to me customer
success is an integral part of the of
customer experience again obviously
depending on the type of company brand
service or whatever you're
you're talking about um
but
to put very simply and i'm sorry if it
sounds like a cliche but customer
experience is how
your brand makes customers feel
and again it's something i repeat all
the time to my students
and customer experience is yes we have
kpis and you know there's a lot of data
and a lot of measurement and and you
have to be able to be data driven
and but at the end of the day it's also
something very intangible that you can't
really grab hold on in it and feel and
and it's really about
a whole like holistic uh set of things
that at the end just uh
incite and trigger emotions with your
end customer or user and
right i know it i know it's a bit it's a
bit vague maybe but that that no no no
it makes perfect sense but my question
is you know i
throughout my my courses in this field
like you keep coming back to this moment
of delight of the customer what is the
delight moment right and i'm thinking to
myself well i wonder 20 years ago did
people ask themselves what is the
delight moment of our product i i i
don't recall in literature or looking at
case studies of companies 20 years ago
30 years ago right that customers were
so much in the forefront
to the effect that it is today how do
you explain this transition that that we
went under here
right so that the light moment uh that
you're talking about was coined as the
the wow uh zappos was like uh you know
very famous to coining that that wow
effect or wow moment and and
a lot of companies try to mimic it to
this day
um
i
i really think it's about a
very carefully crafting
a set of
different initiatives and different
experiences
and different touch points
and
and it's really important to remember
that
the way
customers feel and again i keep going
back to feelings because emotions are a
very strong
a part of customer experience okay and
again we can measure everything but at
the end of the day it's emotions it's
feelings and
customers have those emotions before
they even use your product or your brand
or your service it begins way before
that it begins with word of mouth it
begins with some review they read on on
trustpilot it begins with some word of
mouth or some post that they saw um you
know on on on any any type of social
media platform and
and it's just it there's so many so many
elements and so many factors involved
into that
incredible and if you're looking at
the way that you're thinking about
customers within an organization you
know 360 degrees and and now you have
the customer portion of this
organization
early 2022 i feel a little confused
about
you know where priorities are when to
get when to start thinking about this
concretely within our human resources
what how big a part is in our team how
do you go about resolving this as a
leader as vice president of customer
experiences and not in one but in
several organizations and having seen
this transition the world has gone
through in the last 20 years
great question so
first i'll start with the disclaimer i'm
not trying to bash any of my my amazing
product managers and product executive
colleagues but and again it's an it's a
generalization also
but i've seen in a lot of organization
organizations uh
product leaders the first thing they do
when they talk about go to market or
developing a new product or feature or
whatever is they go and they do
competitor analysis right what do our
competitors do what's what's out there
how do we
break through the cluster and so on and
so forth and
again not all of them but that is like
the
you know the the classic approach and
oftentimes peop that those leaders
forget and those product managers forget
to go and do a
customer interviews and go speak to
customers and go understand exactly what
the customer needs uh and then do some
iterations do some mvps and learn from
that and and i think
when
a big part of of being a customer
experience
leader in any type of company any type
of the organization is being able to
let's be honest it's a it's a it's a
daily i don't want to say war but it's a
daily struggle because the blanket is
always uh too small and resources are
being pulled from every single direction
there's scarce resources right there's
never enough
r d and and budgets and and talents to
to do everything
and
and as a customer experience leader or
manager your goal is to advocate
for what our customers need and you know
going back to data that needs to be
backed with mountains of data and
mountains of of uh
actual information tangible information
that you can then bring as is kind of
like proof or as an an argument
um
but
it's not easy right you you are
basically
uh in the in the center in the heart of
the company uh trying to
kind of like be the knight
and and be that that that one person
that's always putting the customer or
the customers at the forefront uh when
right and the struggle doesn't end in
the
product specifications and the prd and
all that analysis that
that's just where it starts because now
you've actually
attracted the customers and now the
experience not not the majority of the
experience is beginning right right and
then we talk about uh
you know i was using the leaky bucket as
an example in a recent post that i wrote
and uh you know then retention comes
into play and and churn and how do we
get repeat customers and how do we
increase uh
a lifetime value and and there's there's
so many matrix uh but again i i really
really think at the end of the day um
and i've seen examples in my career and
i think there's plenty of uh of examples
throughout history and
of companies that were able to and i
know now it's like a worn out and it's
like a buzzword that everybody uses but
this customer obsession or customer
centricity or call whatever you want but
being able to focus on the customer and
every single uh decision making every
single planning every single move that
you do
um like you said in the planning stage
and then after when when there's an mvp
or when you're already you know when you
already launched your your product or
your service or a new feature
you always have to focus on what's going
on with my customers is it working
what's the voice of customer do i listen
to the feedback do i make iterations
based on feedback um
and again it's very very difficult right
because every single manager and
stakeholder in the company and
you know and again i'm not trying to to
bash anyone we all have our kpis and we
all have our uh you know and end of co
end of quarter end of the year goals
that we need to meet um but sometimes
um you know when we focus on those uh
so-called vanity matrix and we don't
think about okay what's you know what's
our customers
wanting from us and are we meeting those
expectations that is the long term uh
road to success in my opinion
what what do you get really good at as a
leader in customer experience you know
seeing company after company seeing all
these different examples watching the
evolution take place what do you
personally get really good at
so listen i i i think
let's let's take the
the let's take wix and gusty as an
example i've seen at wix i've seen
a customer obsession when it wasn't even
like such a such a big buzzword really
propelling and accelerating the company
obviously it wasn't the only
contributing factor right it was an
amazing product and a lot of other
things that contributed to the
stellar success of the company but
this is a company that was customer
centric from day one
and i've seen the contribution uh
to the success of wix then in guest day
i've seen how
being customer
centric and focused on customers
helped a prop tech company navigate
through probably one of the most
difficult times for a prop tech company
to
uh to operate in right through them the
through the pandemic through
unforeseeable challenges and so on and
so forth and that those relationships
that the company was able to build with
it with the customer base uh
was huge in terms of uh
enabling coming out of it even stronger
and
and so
as i said i think if companies
are able
to really stay
focused on the customers
at any given moment in in their
life cycle regardless of uh do they just
raise a huge round of funding or are
they just you know releasing the first
mvp or are they a well-established
company that uh
you know that has been around for you
know a decade two decades whatever once
you lose that connection to your
customers
it's probably not a good sign
right so one of the things that you know
just about that that i'm always so
curious about you know i'm imagining
myself in a leadership situation within
a startup and i'm you know pushing
forward and i'm making daily decisions
how do i know when there's red flags
that come about especially when it comes
to my users and customers right because
sometimes it feels like the leadership
can be so disconnected from from the the
end users who are actually receiving the
product and saying okay this is not what
i actually expected
so how can you know
startups said at any stage
think through
you know what what is what are those red
flags
so it's a good question i'll
i'll try to give a as simple as answer
as i can obviously there's a lot of
other factors that that you know uh can
be involved but to me it's finding a
good balance between
the more hands-on and more more personal
experience and i'll explain what i mean
and the data-driven experience a data
driven approach data driven i think we
all understand you need to
be able to have thresholds and have
alerts and have very clear kpis um you
know
in a recent interview i talked about the
context per order which is a kpi that
amazon
famously used for many many years or in
other words what's the ratio between the
interactions uh that i have with my
customers to the ratio of orders that i
get from my customers and it's such a
simple yet powerful a kpi
and it can be a translated and mimicked
regardless of what
a company you're working so that's
number one data
has to be always at the forefront and
then the other side of the coin is the
more personal uh aspect and
uh
i always i i always use the brian chesky
example uh he was interviewed in in
masters of scale by reed hoffman and uh
he's telling about his first days in the
y combinator and he's in san francisco
you know doing the whole accelerator and
and and that stuff and then someone
asked them like
wait your your customers are in new york
and you're in san francisco right now
and this is back in the day when they
had like i don't know a few dozen hosts
and they're all in new york city
the next day is on a flight to new york
knocking on on the doors of the hosts
sitting down with them for coffee and
just listening to them what what's
working for you what's not working for
you what's your challenges in terms of
managing a short-term rental uh property
and so on and so forth and
and i think
those user interviews
are so critical
and sometimes you can have
all the data in the world and and
amazing a
bi and and data teams and and everything
is in place if you don't also add that
personal dimension
and create some sort of mix and balance
between those two you're probably
missing a lot of very valuable
data points and touch points that you
want to be able to
get like a feel for
but i think also what i'm getting from
this story that perhaps it's not just
about the user interviews and it's about
the decision to act quickly i mean a
huge part of this is the unconventional
idea that
that he'll get on a plane the next day
go to new york and and and probably
shift around a lot of priorities to make
sure that there is room for this and
that and i think that it comes down to
my to you know a deeper question of you
know are we
you know the good leaders do are these
the leaders that know how to prioritize
when you know either the fan
and it's too late but but also know to
to periodically check in and prioritize
these things above the day-to-day
craze that's happening especially as
we're seeing the market today that the
expectation is to evolve way faster than
your customers can evolve with you and i
think that those are some some really
interesting points but doron take me
back a little bit way way back before
the special olympics in this nature
growing up
what are you fascinated about i'm
guessing it's not the lean startup and
and and all these different case studies
what were you deeply curious about
not yet um
it may sound funny but
uh i was deeply deeply and i'm still by
the way deeply fascinated by lego
and to this day i'm an avid lego
collector and wow and i built a
lego
and
all the time
and i was trying to think about it
before before the the interview and and
to me what's what really
drew me and i think what still draws me
draws me to lego
is
there's no there's no there's no limits
right
yes there's specific
packages that you buy and you have a set
of instructions and everything is laid
out for you but
when i was a kid it was like you have
you know a mountain full of bricks and
you can do whatever you want with them
and i know it sounds a bit uh you know
childish but it excites me to this day
you know this this um there's no limits
there there's so many possible there's
endless possibilities
and i just yeah i i haven't to this day
i have a lego addiction
incredible yeah
sources of inspiration for you
in the world as you walk around what
makes you stop
and
you know we just stop and wander for a
few minutes
so
i hope it doesn't sound dark
uh i i've come across a lot of
inspirational stories and and and i and
i post
about a lot of inspirational stories
that touch me
but if we're talking about inspiration
as a source of motivation
to me
it's not really inspirational stories of
success or or anything like that
i feel like i have an innate fear in me
of mediocrity
i just i i it's it's something that that
haunts me
on a daily basis with everything that i
do it's just a genuine
fear
of mediocrity and and i know it's again
i know it sounds uh
maybe a bit dark but to me this is my
biggest motivation uh i can i can hear
the most inspirational stories and again
i i'm very fortunate i hear a lot of
inspirational stories probably on a
daily basis but at the end of the day
what really you know puts puts the fire
under my
you know un under my bum and gets me
going is that innate fear of mediocrity
and maybe failure so
thank you
i really really want to thank you this
was so enjoyable the time went by way
way too fast and i appreciate your time
and your energy and your effort and the
work that you're doing and and i can't
wait to continue learning a lot from you
and your work so thank you and stay safe
and stay healthy i appreciate it thank
you so much
[Music]